début d'une merveilleuse semaine de
boulot sur le chantier j'avais toujours
eu l'impression d'être pris dans une
opération escargot
on avance s'il vous plaît on accélère je
voulais seulement aller un peu plus vite
tu vas arrêter oui avec cette histoire
de vitesse conduite un peu de la vie tu
appelles ça une vie tu es un escargot
pas une voiture j'ai ça en moi non plus
un pas sans toi d'or qui tu l'as dit la
nature mère nature
je voudrais aller fille je l'échappée
belle
ma foi
oh non
qu'est ce qui arrive ça doit être mon
jour des choses un petit peu dépaysé
j'imagine l'escargot de chardin je crois
qu'on a un pleurnichard
allez on y va en arabe ont marre
on
mon nom turbo j'aurais trop changé de
nom